once you see this video my hope is that
you will be able to look at and
appreciate manga in a completely
different way there are obvious and
clear issues with Dragon Ball super
manga that are persisting and are
largely going unnoticed by the vast
majority of fans out there so let's fix
that here's the rundown a few weeks back
I decided to pick apart a few pages off
Dragon Ball super manga for fun to show
that it could be so much better than it
currently is since then I've received
messages both privately and publicly
over various social networking sites
hundreds of comments and some artists
even working on their own comics reached
out because the points and changes I
made the video which got me thinking why
did the changes I made to the visuals
resonated with so many people and I
think I know why so for your viewer
satisfaction I will be walking through
my process discussing and showing a host
of panels I changed within the Dragon
Ball super manga today but before we get
to the artwork it's important to answer
this question first why did the changes
I made to supers manga resonate with so
many people well the answer came about
when I stumbled upon this article it
discussed communication but more
specifically how we receive information
from others I'm gonna talk about sciency
stuff for a little bit now yeah science
look I'll keep it brief but I promise
it's important and interesting using
various research papers published in the
1960s seriously stay with me a formula
was devised which implied during certain
conversations 7% of what we express is
through words
38% through the tone of voice we use and
55% is communicated through body
language and if you doubt that's true
and you think only words are important
here's a computer saying one of my
favorite lines from battle of gods I
won't let you destroy my world yeah
the exact same no that information has
its flaws but it helped answer the
question I had before why were people
impressed or surprised about what I did
with the Dragon Ball super manga we are
all aware of the words we choose and the
tone in which we say those words for the
most part however the vast majority of
people don't pay much attention to how
they compose themselves when they speak
how they stand hold their arms the
facial expressions they use etc we
really don't there are body language
experts that work in police
interrogation for the simple
fact people communicate through
nonverbal means much more than they are
aware of and the same way you are not
aware of what you are communicating
through body language most people read
it but they do so unconsciously and
that's the important part if we look at
the super manga everyone could critique
what's written it's what we interact
with on the page the most but if the
writing was hypothetically for the sake
of this argument perfectly fine I could
easily see this conversation take place
between two fans hey man what do you
think of the Dragon Ball super manga
it's okay it's not really my thing
but I thought you loved Dragon Ball
you're a lifelong fan aren't you yeah
but there's just something about it
that's just not grabbing me you know
this nebulous feeling of disinterest
that is felt in the community towards
Toyota as manga I think in part has to
do with one crucial aspect of the mangas
creation process many people don't
consider composition composition is the
body language of a manga or comic book
if it's good we largely don't notice it
but if it's bad we become disinterested
in what we are reading for reasons that
might not even be known to us all right
so we're on the same page here
composition is vitally important but
where does the Dragon Ball super manga
falter when it comes to composition I am
so glad you asked let's look at chapter
41 the unveiling of mastered ultra
instinct in both the Dragon Ball super
manga and anime to some extent during
the tournament of power they never
managed to solve the problem of how to
make most of the reaction shots in the
stands interesting reaction shots are
needed to keep the pace of the battle
without them believe it or not the fight
becomes dull however Toyo taro tends to
use the same reaction shots over and
over and over again
now reaction shots are needed but if
they are used in this way it comes off
as a crutch and only serves to make the
reader feel a sense of deja vu with that
said let's see if we can guess what is
missing from the beginning of this scene
page 1 chapter 41 any ideas how about
when I show you pages 2 & 3
two words establishing shot an
establishing shot is typically a wide
view of the area in which the scene is
taking place this allows us to
understand what's nearby who is in the
scene and where the characters are in
relation to one another so right off the
bat we are missing a crucial part of the
battle scene and no amount of me
rearranging the panels is going to fix
that so yeah great great start so far
but let's ignore that and move on to the
actual fight itself let's look at pages
2 & 3 for now the first thing I notice
when I see Toyo Terra's work is how busy
it looks there are times when he does a
fine job but more often than not his
work is quite visually noisy and if
composition aka manga body language is
important then we need to be able to
understand that easily there are a
number of attributes which caused this
visual noises in manga from Clara's work
we noticed that he likes to use a lot of
panels as well as that he likes to
implement speed lines and textures
whenever he can
textures are great and speed lines as
the name implies adds a sense of drama
and monk speed to illustration and
Toyama used them also to abundance and
great effect however the combination of
speed lines textures and a heavy
reliance on a high number of panels per
page leads to simply put a cluttered
visual looking at page 3 especially when
shown next to page 2 looks exceptionally
line heavy when compared with this fight
scene with Raddatz from Toriyama oh hey
look an establishing shot as you can see
the Toriyama fight scene despite using
more characters at one time it's much
easier to understand in a short time
this is primarily achieved through
Toriyama's less is more approach in the
scene with Raddatz we see our hero's
brace for impact
and boom Raddatz is there we don't need
to see anything else and as a result the
images are bigger give us more time to
understand them however I will concede
that this is totally different to what
is being shown in the Dragon Ball super
manga so I think it's fair to make
allowances for that speaking of which
here it is the biggest difference
between my version and turret arrows is
probably at the beginning of page 3
usually what I had to work with I tried
to compile the dodge panel and wind up
punch panel into one in my version I
also took the speed lines out to give
reader a sense that this is a moment
frozen in time a sort of slow motion
effect if you will I use this also to
juxtapose the final panel on the page
where's your in counter-attacks Goku
there's a not-so-subtle light versus
dark theme implemented by taking this
approach to okay so now that we
understand what visual noisiness is and
can now finally hear what the
composition is trying to tell us let's
look at other weak aspects of Toyota ROS
game specifically something I find
almost as irritating as visual noisiness
and that is something I am dubbing
visual itch so what is it and how do we
scratch it well in order to scratch an
itch we need to figure out what exactly
is irritating so let's see if you can
see what my issue is with this image
I'll give you a hint it's to do with the
top and bottom of these two pages and
this problem persists in almost every
single page of Toyota ROS work and that
is his work is not boxed in it runs off
the page image borders running off the
page calls a sense of unease to the
reader and not in a good way for
instance if you are looking at a picture
online you probably position it such
that you can see all of the image on the
screen typically you don't leave the
image on the border are slightly under
because there is a nagging sensation in
our brains telling us to scroll down
because we might not have all of the
image visible so when Toyo taro leaves
this image run off the bottom of the
page the readers are given a feeling
that they want to scroll down or reveal
more of the image in other words there's
a sense that they aren't seeing the full
picture from a psychological standpoint
this makes sense and when we compare it
with Toriyama's box approach everything
looks tidier and easier to read as a
result another added benefit to this
practice is that it allows the artist to
think outside the box from time to time
for example take a look at what I did
with the same scene keeping the panel
boxes closed on the bottom and top I was
able to break those rules specifically
with the character's anatomy to create
the illusion they are reaching outside
of their box this adds energy to a scene
catch the reader's eye and helps your
image leap off the page now that we've
covered the visual noise and the visual
itch two aspects I don't think get
nearly enough attention I think it's
time to discuss the part of Toyota ROS
game that gets it the most flack I am
speaking about the visual stench what I
mean by visual stage is the
that comes over you when you were
reading through Toyota Rose manga this
feeling tells you there's something
fishy about this and in many aspects
you'd be right
I'm sure many of you have seen this if
you go around Twitter the same time the
manga chapters are released each month
propagating the web are scandalous
images showing the world Toyota Rose
proclivities when it comes to drawing
and the bad habits he has as an artist
people complain fervently about his lack
of knowledge when it comes to Anatomy
and yeah I can see why that might be an
issue for some but for me the visual
standing comes from his seeming
inability to avoid using the same poses
over and over and over again
one of his lesser-known repeating
offences are the boring flat side
profile combat shots in this chapter
alone there are four panels that have
this boring composition that angle is
not good it shows no depth and it's like
something a four-year-old would compose
if he was gifted the abilities to know
taro has it requires no creativity and
no imagination I hate using this word
but it's lazy from a creative
perspective oh and speaking of lazy the
very best page in this chapter is page
12 aka the reveal of mastered ultra
instinct they're genuinely isn't much I
changed with this page beyond closing
the boxes because Torterra losses runoff
images but aside from that I wouldn't
change anything the images are clear
striking and expressive and wouldn't you
know it its composition is pretty much
entirely copied from the poses to the
expressions to the panel structure of
Akira Toriyama's Goku vs. piccolo jr.
fight look guys I understand there are
those out there that love Toyo taro and
Dragon Ball super smug and that's
perfectly fun more power to you as far
as I'm concerned Who am I to say what
you can enjoy and what you should enjoy
however if you are out there looking to
get into the industry and to start your
own comic
I implore you to not use toy or Tarot as
an example of what you think you should
be aiming for look at the past four
incredible manga cars like Osamu Tezuka
Genji ito
Yusuke Murata or even akira toriyama
there are tons of incredibly
Valentin monica's that have paved the
way and are continuing to pave the way
in some respects for young and
up-and-comers right now you are part of
a generation that has access to more
information and resources than any other
generation that has come before you I
truly believe that the greatest mangas
and comic book artists to date will
emerge in the next 20 years because of
this fact but that won't happen if we
act like visually uninteresting
composition full of noise
sloppy panel structure and suspect
referencing ethics are clogging our
perception of what makes a great or even
competent Monica and to all the aspiring
comic book and manga artists that this
video might reach do not give up doing
things the right way might seem
difficult but you have way more
potential than you give yourself credit
for you do not need to take shortcuts
work hard practice draw create innovate
improve change rice inspire repeat I
believe in you you are better than this
thank you so much for watching